bonsoir et bienvenue pour le 7-8 l'actu
sur tv fil 78 nouvelle édition du
journal de la rédaction voici les titres
de ce 4 juin 2014 médina mouche le
tireur présumé de la tuerie du musée
juif de bruxelles présenté au parquet
général de versailles cet après midi il
a refusé son extradition vers la
belgique un spectacle de désolation la
base de loisirs de trappes ou 800 mètres
carrés du centre équestre ont été
ravagés par les flammes aucune victime
les chevaux ont aussi été sauvés par le
gardien présent cette nuit le maire de
maurepas grégory est resté avec les
gilet jaune hier soir avant la séance du
conseil municipal est là réaffirmer avec
ce collectif de parents d'élèves son
opposition à la réforme des rythmes
scolaires
il refuse l'extradition vers la belgique
médine mouche le principal suspect dans
la tuerie du musée juif de bruxelles le
24 mai dernier a refusé d'être remis à
la justice belge cet après midi il s'est
en effet vu notifier par la cour d'appel
de versailles et le mandat d'arrêt
européen qui le visent il passera la
nuit dans la maison d'arrêt de bois
d'arcy avant de revenir demain devant la
cour d'appel de versailles d'après son
avocat l'homme est aujourd'hui sera nous
disons simplement que il est français il
a en france aujourd'hui il a été
interpellé en france et il n'y a pas de
raison puisqu'elle le 10 ans français
sont compétents pour pouvoir le juger on
voit pas de raison pour qu'il soit remis
aux autorités belges nous allons demain
défendre notre position
la coup d'appel la chambre d'instruction
de la cour d'appel va statuer sur le
mandat qui a été décernée sur le fait
que mon client refuse d'être remis aux
tout est belge et nous allons défendre
notre position la coup d'appel pointe à
une décision et par la suite nous avions
en études à l'assemblée cette semaine le
projet de loi relatif à la prévention de
la récidive et de l'individualisation
des peines un projet porté par la garde
des sceaux christiane taubira et plus
communément appelée réforme pénale à la
prison de bois d'arcy les agents de
probation chargés d'aider les détenus à
se réinsérer gère déjà plus de 100
dossiers chacun et on y compte 835
condamné pour seulement 5 108 places le
secrétaire général adjoint du syndicat
ufap y travaillent et pour lui elle la
possibilité de développer les bracelets
électroniques pour les peines de moins
de 5 ans est une bonne idée il faut
néanmoins des moyens financiers il
revient aussi sur l'idée de la difficile
reconstruction des victimes si
l'agresseur n'est pas incarcéré
moi je suis pour aussi quelque part les
peines alternatives à la détention mais
à condition qu'ils aient des moyens
parce que si vous mettez pas de moyens
là derrière si vous faites une loi et
que vous mettez pas de moyens vous
mettez pas de conseillers d'insertion et
de probation d'éducateurs spécialisés
pour les mineurs vous mettez pas de
personnel de surveillance aussi pour
aller mettre les blast électronique ou
puis des personnes à proximité des gens
pour les aider à repartir sur de bonnes
bases
si vous voulez laisser sur le bord de la
route vous y arriverez pas et donc
forcément ils reviendront présent mais
un autre problème qui se pose c'est que
bien souvent il ya des gens qui sont
prêts à moins de 5 ans mais qui sont là
pour atteinte à la personne
comment on place la victime là dedans
comment se place la victime parce que
bien souvent les victimes ont besoin qui
est une peine prononcée de prison pour
que et puissent éventuellement faire un
deuil sûr je dis pas sur un décès mais
sur sur une agression qu'elle puisse se
reconstruire après par rapport à ça donc
la problématique de la victime se passe
là propos recueillis par claire cambier
plaisir et long cours ou encore bois
d'arcy voici quelques-unes des communes
opposées à une application dès la
rentrée prochaine de la réforme des
rythmes scolaires à maurepas le maire a
rejoint ce combat soutenus par les
parents le conseil municipal de mardi
soir a permis de débattre sur ce thème
olivier maniscalco elodie mois
gilet jaune à maurepas mardi soir
parents enfants et élus se sont réunis
devant l'hôtel de ville pour protester
contre la réforme des rythmes scolaires
et soutenir l'équipe municipale qui
réclame son report d'une année dans la
commune vivement critiqué par les
manifestants la réforme est jugée
inadaptée notamment par certains
enseignants qui préféreraient plutôt
modifier le programme je suis pas sûr
qu'aujourd'hui
la réforme des rythmes scolaires qui a
un peu perdu de sa valeur par des
regroupements de temps parfois les
après-midis apporte le nécessaire pour
les enfants en tant qu'enseignante de
ses reins moi je me rends compte qu'en
effet le programme de sylvain est un
programme qui est très chargé il n'y a
pas que dans cette classe que le
programme est chargé est ce qu'on ne
peut pas penser à ré aplanir les
programmes pour qu'il soit accessible à
tous les enfants autre point d'ampleur
abordés par la municipalité le coût
élevé de la réforme
400000 euros seraient nécessaires pour
appliquer les nouveaux rythmes scolaires
amoureux pas des nouveaux rythmes
scolaires dont la mise en place était
débattu le soir même au conseil
municipal
nous avons souhaité porter au débat ce
soir démocratiquement au sein de cette
assemblée pour voilà envisager un report
de cette réforme parce que premièrement
nous la pensions contraire à l'intérêt
de l'enfant nous n'avons pas les moyens
financiers de pouvoir l'appliquer 400000
euros à la collectivité ça fait quatre
points d'impôts et donc nous nous
refusons d'augmenter les impôts des
moyens à l'issue du conseil un voeux de
la municipalité a été émis pour un
report d'un an des nouveaux rythmes
scolaires à meurent pas les communes ont
jusqu'au 6 juin pour présenter leurs
dossiers de réformes 20 villes dans les
yvelines n'ont encore rien déposé si un
conseil d'éducation doit se réunir vers
le 20 juin pour statuer c'est au final
l'académie de versailles qui fixera les
horaires d'entrée et de sortie de classe
applicable à la rentrée 2014
l'actualité locale également marqués par
l'incendié d'une partie du centre
équestre de la base de loisirs de
trappes nous sommes en ligne avec
frédéric bordier le directeur de ce site
bonsoir à vous
l incendie s'est déclaré dans la nuit de
lundi à mardi huit cents mètres carrés
d'un hangar réduits en fumée que
s'est-il passé cette nuit là
est bien le
hangar à paille on ne venait d'être
livré des ballots de paille en gare et à
craquer et puis en pleine nuit bas avec
de feu s'est déclaré en plein centre du
regard la cause exacte de cet incendie
en cours se poursuit toute la semaine
mais bon voilà il ya par ont fait que la
cause de lectrique et des carpes et
lapins on connaît pas l'origine exacte
donc ça pourrait être un incendie
criminel c'est ce que vous avez une
piste privilégiée en tout cas où des
inquiétudes autour de ça
non on reste vigilants là on n'a pas
d'inquiétude particulière on reste
simplement vigilant bien sûr on a mis
une société sécurité hier
ce qu'on voudrait pas que quand on a
encore de la paille un peu étalée
partout pour qu'elles évitent de
redémarrer je suis très très bon état
donc on admire la jambe sécurité mais on
n'est pas plus inquiet que ça tape le
mur et le vigilant il n'y a aucune
victime les chevaux ont également été
sortis rapidement par le gardien sur le
plan matériel on parle d'une facture de
plus de deux cent mille euros 300 mille
euros c'est bien ça on connaît pas
encore l'évaluation des dégâts parce
qu'il ya énormément de matériel comme
but de nombreux tracteurs des calèches
du matériel de l'outillage
il faudrait que c'était une fille à un
dépôt à gré
on connaît pas encore la facture quelles
conséquences pour les activités avec
l'été qui approche alors les cours
continuent normalement les travaux
continuent normalement puisque c'est sur
toi pas de local et un pack d'entretien
puisque les tracteurs et machines
agricoles servait surtout à l'entretien
soca et du matériel donc en tout cas en
terme de cours et de d'animation ça ne
change en rien à la qualité du champion
merci frédéric barbier directeur de la
base de loisirs de trappes ou le centre
équestre vient en partie d'être ravagée
par les flammes les causes exactes de
l'incendié ne sont pas encore connus
l'invité de ce journal à présent c'est
françoise lisons le roi prix poésie
yvelines des collégiens 2014 pour les
bulls ce livre hommage à votre père
bonsoir et bienvenue en plateau vous
êtes né en belgique professeur de
français plusieurs livres édités dans
votre pays en france également avant de
parler de ce dernier ouvrage justement
un mot sur cette distinction qui a été
offerte par des jeunes lecteurs de votre
sentiment peut-être c'est pas la
première fois que vous recevez des prix
c'est peut-être la première fois par des
plus jeunes oui c'est la première fois
qu'un
collectif de jeunes ma tribu a pris j'en
suis vraiment très heureuse parce que
d'une part les les jeunes ne font pas de
cadeaux et si c'était
une nomination spontanée est tellement
lumineuse comme ça et d'autre part parce
que j'ai enseigné pendant toute ma vie
enfin pendant 40 ans environ à des
jeunes de 12 à 15 ans et tout à coup
c'est cette reconnaissance ne m'arrive
et vous les avez rencontré ces jeunes on
envoie quelques images c'est le
quatrième prix poésie poésie yvelines il
a réuni onze collégiens de tout le
département et cette année vous je le
disais vous les avez rencontré c'était à
l'université de versailles-saint-quentin
aujourd'hui nous y étions à catherine
plateau et jonathan avait manne pour ce
reportage
émotion c'est le mot qui qualifie le
mieux le sentiment qui a parcouru
l'assemblée de collégiens réuni ce
mercredi pour le prix poésie vinh 2014
un prix remis à une hauteur belge pour
son ouvrage les bouloches qui rend
hommage à son tour on s'était vraiment
l'émotion de la
2de l'auteur vis-à-vis de son père et
leur présenter comme un enfant qui va
enfin qui est qui il y avait donc des
actions d'enfants qui pouvait bien se
comporter comme tels la poésie que je
n'avais jamais vraiment prête attention
avant le prix donc dans le prix des
livres qui m'ont aimé dès que j'ai moins
aimé et sa une sur dix comptent vraiment
différents types de d'écriture comme
aurélien ils sont près de 400 collégiens
avoir participé à ce prix il avait le
choix entre quatre auteurs et pour
françoise lisons le roi qui a été
professeur de français pendant 35 ans
c'est une heureuse rencontre ça donne de
la force ça veut dire aussi que
que les peut tabler sur le
l'intelligence des jeunes et sur leur
capacité de recevoir des
une parole venus d'ailleurs ou une
parole qui n'est pas nécessairement
écrite pour les enfants
nous venons de bien
ça leur fait découvrir des poètes
contemporains encore vivant dans qu'ils
apprécient et le retour qu'on a
systématiquement c'est qu'on a tout le
temps des élèves qui nous disent ben
écoutez madame moi je n'ai pas trop la
poésie et ben maintenant j'aime bien ça
prouve aux gens que la bougie est fait
pour eux voilà l'émotion car est adonné
françoise là c'est trois ans que 350
élèves qui étaient présents ils
ressentiront pas avec autre chose le
quatrième prix poésie yvelines a réuni
cette année onze collèges de tout le
département
le prix poésie blinn des collégiens à
2014 qui est donc l'invité de ce journal
du 4 juin votre avis peut-être sur la
mise en place d'un tel prix est organisé
par le conseil général des yvelines et
la maison de la poésie également à
aiguilles en cours c'est un bon moyen
d'initier les plus jeunes à la poésie
qui peut leur faire peur peut-être oui
certainement je pense que c'est quand
même extraordinaire de voir un grand un
énorme public de collégiens ou des gens
de 12 à 15 ans qu'ils soient rassemblés
autour de d'apprendre d'un tel projet et
la maison de la poésie des yvelines je
trouve ça fait merveille tout simplement
parce que
la poésie c'est une c'est une langue
alors donner accès à la langue de
quelqu'un à la langue d'un poète c'est
magnifique et je pense à plusieurs
langues parce qu'on fouille avait il y
avait plusieurs plusieurs auteurs et
c'est vrai que c'est moi qui ai eu le
prix mais l'autre les autres les autres
textes étaient très intéressant de toute
façon je les ai entendus je pense que
les jeunes sont bien plus près qu'on ne
le pense à recevoir cette parole
poétique et ifs le fait d'aller vers de
leur donner cette occasion c'est
magnifique quand j'ai moi-même été
professeur de français donc j'ai fait
tout ce que je pouvais pour pour faire
passer la poésie dans mes classes et si
je retrouve cette énergie décuplez vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure les jeunes ne
font pas de cadeaux lorsqu'ils font des
critiques ils ont rédigé des fiches
critique vous avez échangé avec eux vous
en retirez quoi quels enseignements pour
vous attendent en tant qu'auteur aussi
par rapport à ce qu'ils ont pu vous dire
ce qui est des magnifiques c'est que la
la la première critique que j'ai entendu
c'est exactement c'était exactement ce
que j'avais voulu dire le monde le
moment où j'ai décidé d'écrire ce livre
était venue de là et la jeune fille qui
avait écrit ce texte et d'autres aussi
par ailleurs ont mis le doigt sur sur
ceux sur l'essentiel et il envoie
précisément c'était sûr c'est à cet
instant où le où le père devient devient
enfin quitte son rôle de père sévère et
2 et 2 et de patriarche pour redevenir
un enfant tu as moi j'ai eu ce sentiment
maternel vis-à-vis de mon père tout à
coup et j'ai compris que tout est là
toute sa vie était là dans ce dossier
dans cet instant là puisque c'est un
livre que vous avez rédigé en hommage à
votre père justement on va y venir juste
auparavant chaque soir nous réalisons un
micro trottoir qui élit à notre invité
la question que nous sommes allés poser
aujourd'hui peut-être de manière un peu
provocante a forcément je le concède à
quoi sert la poésie vos réponses
c'est de raconter certaines histoires à
faire transparaître certains moments de
sa vie
comme musique en fait un petit peu mais
qu'elle soit transport transposée par
écrit mais ces sentiments
faire passer des messages quoi encore un
peu tout quoi ses sources d'inspiration
c'est une source de détente peut-être
d'évasion vous écrire un message à nos
amis ou en amoureux que sur de plus
sympa plus
plus romantique du sort de ces deux de
rythme et les fera changer le monde par
exemple si on veut c'est tout ce que je
pense à s'évader en fait à s'évader dans
leurs lectures dans leur idée pourquoi
de mission pour la poésie c'est très
lourd cette charge pour un poète
pourquoi vous avez fait le choix
justement de cette écriture très
poétique finalement pour votre ouvrage
je pense que la poésie m'est tombé
dessus depuis quand j'étais petit déjà
et puis si ce sujet là c'est à poser
c'est vrai que moi la poésie ne vient
pas du ciel elle la jeune femme
l'arrachent je la prends je la rage de
mes tripes et j'essaie de l'offrir et
j'essaie de toucher chaque fois là la
même petite chose qui qui qui me semble
essentiel et d'aller au plus juste je
pense qu'il ya une ruche une véritable
recherche à un gros travail de
rabotage que j'ai environt mise en plis
ce menuisier parce que je pense pas que
ce soit uniquement intellectuelle ya
aussi le travail du matin du matériau
qu'est la langue et vous écrivez depuis
très jeune avec votre premier ouvrage
est un sel dans mon premier contrat je
commence à écrire ses femmes ou d'un
ouvrage dictionnaire je voulais refaire
a du retard le dictionnaire avec
d'autres des initiaux les bouloches ce
sont ces petits brins de tissu que votre
père roulait entre ses paumes c'est bien
ça c'est le titre de cet ouvrage c'est
un souvenir sociable de lui ah oui oui
c'est vrai que c'était un peu comme
s'ils retournaient au nid au fond c'est
je pense que quelqu'un qui a passé toute
sa vie à
des enfants il était instituteur il
jardinier il était historien local et un
jour comme tout le monde un jour on va
vers sa fin et quand j'ai compris qu'il
allait vers sont d'ailleurs je me suis
dit tiens je peux pas laisser partir sa
vous y parlez de cette dernière année
que vous avez vécu avec lui vous avez
commencé à écrire avant même qu'il ne
décède oui oui pourquoi ce choix vous
vous êtes dit c'est un moyen de de ne
pas le laisser partir aussi oui c'est un
moyen de ne pas laisser marquer les
toute façon c'était c'était urgent
urgent que je sais pas ce que parce que
j'ai en fait je ne savais pas comment
allait se terminer sa vie je savais que
ce que c'était là que ça qu'ils allaient
vers la fin mais je ne savais pas donc
je voulais retenir ça et lorsqu'on voit
que les collégiens on était là très ému
alors ce qu'ils ont lu ce livre vous
dites que vous avez réussi à faire un
livre qui touche tout le monde tous les
âges tout le monde même si c'était un
thème très personnel oui oui c'est je
suis si j'étais j'ai été très frappé ce
n'est pas moi qui ai envoyé ce livre à
la maison de la poésie mais le fait de
bain qui fait ce pari de la sélection
est qui et qui par là des jeunes c'est
c'est c'était très émouvant
aujourd'hui ce que vous souhaitez pour
cet ouvrage c'est qu'ils vivent par
lui-même qu'il continue à être transmis
de génération en génération maintenant
que peut-être d'une certaine manière
aussi ça aide aussi en écrivant à faire
son deuil quelque part quelque à
l'avenir vous le souhaitez à cet ouvrage
mais qu'il continue son chemin à travers
à travers d'autres regards les les
jeunes et les aînés tout le monde merci
beaucoup d'être venu sur ce plateau
françoise ils ont le roi a pris poésie
bling des collégiens 2014 pour cet
ouvrage les bouloches qui a beaucoup plu
aux plus jeunes mais qui plaira aussi
forcément aux plus âgés et c est le prix
poésie blinn conseil général des
yvelines avec la maison de la poésie
également merci à vous de la poésie
l'improvisation avec ce soir les demi
finales et la finale de la compétition
intercollèges organisé par déclic
théâtre à 20h30 au scarabée de la
verrière vont s'affronter elle les
établissements recourbé le village de
trapèze stein de magny les hameaux et
l'agio d'elancourt le spectacle sera
filmée par tvfi laissera découvrir
prochainement en intégralité sur notre
antenne culture toujours aurait toujours
à trappes ou le lycée de la plaine de
nous préparer il ya quelques jours sa
semaine des arts le musée de port royal
des champs est associée à l'événement
puisqu'il accueille les productions
annuelles des élèves reportage de
mathilde capbern et et d'élodie
moyrand
j.tomas thiercelin étudiant en terminale
littéraire dans ce lycée de trappes
s'est inscrit à l'option théâtre pour le
bac un moyen de gagner quelques points
mais pas uniquement ce qui me plaît
c'est la liberté de jeu parce que c'est
vrai que tout ce qui est une mise en
scène va on peut mettre notre patte
dessus on peut on peut choisir quel type
de mise en scène on veut faire quel type
de parti pris et c'est vrai que c'est la
liberté
artistique
à l'occasion de la semaine des arts de
l'établissement scolaire plus de 150
élèves tous niveaux confondus sont
invités à présenter leur production
annuelle au musée de port royal des
champs un cadre exceptionnel imprégné de
culture théâtres cinémas aux arts
plastiques ces options restent très
attractives effectivement nos options
sont vraiment plein et c'est à dire
qu'au niveau du jeu de course du
pourcentage d'élèves du lycée
appartenant à l'option théâtre on est on
est dans un pourcentage au niveau
académique kita c'est vraiment très très
élevé voilà donc on est très très
contents parce qu'on est sûr que ça leur
fait énormément de bien selon un rapport
du syndicat national des enseignements
artistiques de la rentrée 2013 la
réforme du lycée a fragilisé les
parcours artistique et le nombre des
ateliers a considérablement baissé
depuis ces dernières années il ya
quelques années il me semble que
l'option théâtre a failli disparaître en
tout cas
oui absolument c'était un dur combat
ce sont des combats qui ne sont jamais
gagnés que provisoirement est à l'heure
actuelle c'est vrai qu'en particulier
les options facultatives les options
artistiques de toutes façons ne se porte
pas bien parce que chacun sait qu'il ya
un manque d'argent
jeudi 5 juin l'ensemble des élèves
présentera ses projets au théâtre de la
ferme de bel ébat à guyancourt
jusqu'au 14 jours le salon des arts de
montigny le bretonneux présente sa 26e
édition une opportunité pour les
artistes amateurs de la région de
présenter leurs oeuvres au public
une cinquantaine d'artistes amateurs
exposent leurs oeuvres au public
jusqu'au 14 mai au conservatoire des
arts à montigny le bretonneux rendez
vous incontournable de la saison
culturelle de la ville le salon des arts
présente des oeuvres techniques
artistiques et plus diverses quatre
grandes séries seront représentées cette
année peintures aquarelles sculptures et
photographies vraiment le salon des arts
a pour but de montrer que quel que soit
son niveau on peut présenter son travail
on peut venir se confronter au regard du
public
de façon plus ou moins modestes donc
c'est vrai qu'il ya des gens qui vont
ont déjà avoir un parcours très
intéressant très poussée puis d'autres
qui vont venir une fois de temps en
temps où tous les ans présentait un
nouveau travail avait forcément parfois
un format un peu plus modeste mais qui
ont la volonté de venir se confronter au
regard du public au regard des
professionnels ou regard des passants
regardent et enfants regard d'un peu
tout toutes les personnes en fait ils
vont passer ici pour célébrer cette 26e
édition le salon met à l'honneur le
photographier ni mon 1 christian lopez
quintas anciens participants récompensé
de nombreuses fois pour ses oeuvres
le salon des arts et compensera chacune
des catégories à l'occasion de la
cérémonie de remise des prix le 14 juin
pour l'heure les visiteurs sont invités
à élire leurs coups de coeur et cette
année les plus jeunes pourront également
décerné le prix du jeune public
du sport à présent pour annoncer la
signature de nissim rafa à laval à 15
ans ce jeune du club de football de
trappes va découvrir le centre de
formation de cette équipe de ligue 2
suivi depuis plusieurs mois par les
observateurs ce sont ces qualités de
travailleur qui ont fait la différence
mais nisima va devoir multiplier les
efforts le projet de formation qu'on a
proposé c'est un projet où il va les
battre il va devoir s'engager à fond il
va être obligé de travailler plus que
les autres gamins donc il va falloir
qu'ils associent donc son travail à
l'école ou au travail sur le terrain
donc le son de formation on a pour
objectif d'allier de et de chercher le
lite moi j'avais jamais bougé train
points et quand je parte il a brassé tes
grands éclats le terrain
c'est impressionnant
interview menée par anthony rech fin du
journal de ce 4 juin je vous retrouve
demain en direct à 18h replay sur notre
site internet et puis n'oubliez pas 24
heures sur 24 les réseaux sociaux
hashtags et 8 actu sur twitter bonne
soirée